what's up theo brandon culture corner
chappelle cat it's your one and only
bosnia and homie
dino christian daltovich i am from
bosnia boston refugee but i ain't got no
accident after man i'm uh
just [ __ ] with you guys but yeah man
i'm a truck driver out here
came here in 95 after the genocide the
war in bosnia
damn uh been through some [ __ ] man been
through prison
uh done some dumb [ __ ] yeah we
all that type of jazz you know all that
says the story all that stuff man
but yeah man i feel like i could add a
good addition to the culture corner
[ __ ] yeah i'm a
pretty normal guy man i like to write
poem
rapping hippity hop don't stop you don't
drop whatever you know [ __ ]
yeah man i attached a rapper video to
this man i don't really know oh
there's a white rapper wow
i feel like that guy's in witness
protection yeah
and he doesn't realize that this is
going on the internet
and like his like witness protection
agent is at home right now going
what the [ __ ] is that he did what idiot
doing
what if he's in whitney's protection
program
you got to be an animal yeah whitney
cummings has a protection program
service
uh here's his rap lately i've been
praying to the one above
i think i've done too many drugs got me
[ __ ] up and i ain't never scared to
die
and i never was and when i go i just
hope i haven't done enough
for my kids sake so when the road got
rough i had to buckle up
yeah this life could get tough you gotta
suck it up you can't be spending your
money you gotta run it up
keep chasing women and you'll end up
looking dumb as [ __ ] i'm saying
look i know what i speak
[Music]
[Music]
stacking freedom lays get the devil out
your face you won't seem
straight yeah that's probably the one
thing i could promise
put it on my kids even swear to my mama
unlike the day i swore to your honor
cause i ain't telling [ __ ] to your honor
i got honor
damn praise christ baby praise god
you know what it wasn't terrible it
wasn't bad it wasn't bad at all
i'm not i'm not mad at him you know what
i mean but he's just out here
driving these streets did he say he's in
la nick
uh no he was like south florida or
something but he's a trucker so he's
always yeah he's all over the country
and drive over here that's your
demographic that would be pretty intense
i think he'd be cool
then bosnians dude and i'll tell you
about them bosnians bro a lot of them
just died a lot of them died and you
know about it brendan or you don't
a little bit doubt that
tell him nick tell him nick i'm looking
up bosnia and genocide right now here we
go
jesus christ that's the cracks
crack staff you got here 8300
killed yeah yeah the bossians have been
through a lot dude i don't know why
people don't like them i haven't met
enough of them to know why people don't
like them yet i like that guy
but we got justin long right here his
new podcast isn't going well
character uh it's justin long dude he
has a new podcast that isn't going well
[Laughter]
let me tell you why i should be the next
guest
on the culture corner name ivan diaz
enriquez
six two tall glass of water peak of my
existence
mexican i know who pancho villa is i
know who richie valens is
selena got pulses of her all over my
walls
yes i do have a friend named hector to
be precise
for american core values bro
i got love apple pie my parents are
divorced didn't do great in school
can't name all the states on the map but
i can tell you what a neutral zone
infraction is
make me your next guest
and this is the witness protection and
it won't be
it looks like kirsten bryant baby unique
it can't be any worse than baby and baby
you need a damn lizard owner too
yeah she brought a [ __ ] snake
this guy was cool though i dig this dude
no you don't dude
i think the white rapper was fun nah huh
you didn't like him yeah i liked him but
i just want you to be honest with
everybody and i want you to be honest
with eric too
uh i think both these guys could be fun
yeah you're right you're right you're
right man they're both good guys no look
i'm happy that this guy sent this in
this guy's obviously from another
country
and he you know who knows even what it's
like over there
and so the fact that he's being able to
get this put together and send this out
he had that
how that soft helmet on um i would have
done a crystalline impersonation i would
have went with a crystalline
impersonation that's what i would have
went with
yeah that'll get you on the show so how
about this here's what i would like to
request out of this young man
we would like to see a crystalline
impersonation if you can do that and
send it in i think that that would
really be interesting brendan what do
you think yeah that'd be fun
there you go sweet and we got one more
uh this guy's uh he went a little long
but he was good let me know if you want
me to cut him off
why does he get cut off he went over he
went over
he's from wisconsin [ __ ] truck
driving in boston
he had two videos had a rap the one
black guy is like this one went a little
long
so it's about two what is he what does
he say like hi i want to be on the show
not a fit am i right folks right what is
happening on this show it's a two minute
long video
you're gonna pick this one up for my
benefit right now
look at that with the show notes like we
better let's have somebody of color
two minutes is an eternity this even has
a filter on it
let's see this guy we even put a filter
too he looked a little lighter in the
original video
i see
it's my initials
i am a black as you can see a lot of
culture going on here
a lot of culture going on here uh but i
am a black
from louisville kentucky okay
i like country music
i'm one of the miami's you know got a
tight three to five
hey i played a little bit of college
football okay
on the lower level ooh he's right on
youtube on a lower level
train a little bit of mma
i watch a little bit of porn
hey man brother praise god we all suffer
and my father
is a pastor who wants me
to follow in his footsteps hates that i
do mma i mean how's this guy different
than chappelle but he has a dash
that's true um he wants me to finish
college
23 right now what is happening i mean
they're just trying not to be raised
wait wait it's not even that
long like he got enough pauses that
field can
step in each thing he gets chimed in
the lord works well you know praise god
my brother we all like like this this
guy's perfect for theo
he could just chime in with i love your
hair you know just in between
this is a lot i love right i love red
tails remember that movie red tails
[Laughter]
oh yeah come on man you go don't roast
the red tails
come on it's pretty good man but i'm
just saying it seemed outlandish but it
was good
um look obviously this guy is a talented
gentleman
um i think we need to i i think we need
to ask him to do something though
b i think have him you know like just
like with the other guys have him create
something that makes it a little bit
more of a vibe do
one of the things that he said yeah i
would also maybe drink a monster energy
drink for a little more energy yeah yeah
something
coffee something it's easy to get five
minutes when you're silent half the time
[Music]